c'est un sujet toujours sensible aide
médicale à mourir et bien le collège des
médecins il ya beaucoup réfléchi
videmment aghtamar altéré sco bonsoir à
vous le projet de loi la loi entre en
vigueur en décembre donc très bientôt
et là on a envoyé aujourd'hui une étape
extrêmement importante les directives
aux médecins oui elles sont prêtes et
elles seront disponibles dès le 10
septembre uniquement pour les médecins
on appelle ça un gué du collège des
médecins mais c'est un document qui est
crucial parce qu'il va permettre au
médecin d'abord de connaître ses droits
c'est important de le mentionner un
médecin peut dire non dans quelles
circonstances est quoi faire si le
patient insiste donc on veut guider le
médecin dans ce nouveau système concret
au québec où l'aide médicale à mourir
votre venir
rejoints et pour ceux qui acceptent et
bien on évoque on rédige la marche à
suivre c'est vraiment très concret à
partir du moment où un médecin dit oui
comment s'y prendre du consentement de
la demande du patient au consentement
donc là on a choisi électrique nikles
exactement par intraveineuse de toutes
les méthodes qui étaient disponibles et
qu'on fait ailleurs dans d'autres pays
où c'est légal on ne choisit que toute
dose l'état fatale sera administré aux
patients au québec par intraveineuse je
vous laisse écouter yves robert docteur
du collège des médecins qui explique
pourquoi on a choisi sept
c'est un gros morceau déclarations on
ouvre une nouvelle porte une nouvelle
dimension une nouveau paradigme en
médecine qui ne s'est jamais fait au
québec
avant ça c'est clair en publiant un
guide mais on le publie
parce que on veut que ce soit bien fait
bien encadré et qui respectent les
normes reconnues et on ne jugeait aussi
que par intraveineuse c'était la méthode
dans les circonstances la plus humaine
est la plus rapide
vous avez rencontré une famille oui qui
attend si je peux dire que la loi soit
un exercice là une femme qui souffre de
post polio pour savoir qu'est ce que ça
représente cette étape loeb est un guide
destiné aux médecins mais qu'est ce que
ça représente pour les gens qui se sont
battus pour avoir accès à l'aide
médicale à mourir et ce qu'on dise en
général
ça leur permet pour la première fois de
fermer les yeux et d'imaginer comment ça
va se passer
d'autant plus que la loi et les
consignes qui ont été publiés
aujourd'hui qu'ils vont être publiés par
le collège des médecins prévoient qu'un
médecin qui accepte de fournir l'aide
médicale à mourir un patient pourra
amener le trou ses trousses de
médicaments importants qui se procura
auprès des pharmaciens pour seulement
dans un hôpital mais à la maison mais
gentil c'est le soin c'est très
important parce que c'est le souhait de
beaucoup beaucoup de gens qui sont en
fin de vie dont la dame que je vous
présente nicole là-dessus tout seul et
que de bonnes nouvelles et je crois que
sa rencontre la l'immense majorité des
souhaits exprimés par les gens mais moi
je le ferai avec mes amis très proches
je le ferai ici je le ferai peut-être au
moment du coucher du soleil c'est
toujours j'appelle ça bourdonne magique
donc ce serait le reflet de toute ma vie
et une mort digne selon c'est vraiment
une révolution il ya encore beaucoup de
médecins qui refusent vous avez des
intrusions vers dans votre reportage ce
soir au 22 heures donc des méthodes
dignes ou jamais on ne fera ça donc
qu'ils disent oui on n'obligera aucun
médecin derrière à le faire mais ils ont
la responsabilité de diriger le patient
vers un médecin qui va ce qui va
accepter
voilà merci thomas je vous en prie